[Music]
all right good afternoon everyone thank
you for joining I'm Dan Belcher I'm one
of the founders of a new startup called
Mable and this is Jo lust one of our
engineers first off I want to thank you
for coming I know we're competing
against lunch and the keynote with Diane
Greene and chef Dean so you must all be
as excited about testing as I am right
right yeah okay good yeah whoo okay so
um we're here to talk about the future
of software testing and the relationship
between sort of testing and GCP and so
one thing I do want to note I am a
former Googler so I'm in recovery
I left the beginning of last year what
it means is that I get to use the same
infrastructure that I used to use when I
was at Google but now I have to pay them
a lot of money for it
but I'm happy to be here we're a very
happy Google customer as I that many of
you are so Mabel we started that company
about a year and a half ago and we
started basically with a very broad sort
of approach and we interviewed hundreds
of software teams and we would sit down
and ask them basically
well what's working well what's not
working well and we heard a bunch of
things so we heard that you know as an
industry we're moving toward continuous
integration continuous delivery DevOps
right raise your hand if you have a lot
of work underway to move to DevOps see
ICD yeah all right right so we're all
going there raise your hand if you feel
like you're done everything's going
great Hey
one two three good and so another thing
that we heard was that there's an
emerging sort of bottleneck in that
journey and that's around software
testing and so the thesis that we
developed is actually that software
testing needs to evolve if we as an
industry can achieve kind of the
potential of DevOps and see ICD ok and
so we set out to build Mabel and you
know this quote left a you know a mark
on me one of the QA leaders that we
spent a lot of time
very early on said hey Dan let me just
put it very directly my teams are
shipping features at a pace now that I
can't keep up there is just not enough
time to test right does that sound
familiar I'm sure to to some of you and
so we figured out we thought well how
can we help him solve this right and
what we believe is that we've reached
sort of a tipping point right as you
start to approach continuous integration
continuous delivery where fundamentally
the ways that we thought about QA
historically don't really apply anymore
right I actually bumped into a former
colleague Marius back there where's
Marius Marius he and I were sitting in a
room probably 13 years ago
planning our annual release at Microsoft
right and so we would talk about okay
how many months how many weeks do we
need for QA for this release and we'd
work through a detailed plan
incorporating all the changes that we
expect it to happen to the product based
on a functional spec right a lot of
people are in functional specs these
days yeah a little bit
and now we're at a point in many
environments or at least we want to get
to a place where change is just
continuous right so you can't plan for a
given change anymore it's continuous
we're talking about you know an order of
magnitude more releases and so the
challenge to us as an industry is how
can we achieve that velocity while still
having confidence that we're delivering
high quality product to our end users so
this is an illustration actually of our
team at Mable's so we only have I don't
know a handful of people contributing to
this project which is our UI project and
we're doing know as many as 100 commits
that get pushed to production every
single week right and this is a little
team now imagine where orders of
magnitude as I know many of your teams
are orders of magnitude larger right so
think of that pace of change how can we
make sure that we're shipping high
quality product and these aren't small
changes we're talking about thousands
tens of thousands of lines of code
shipping to production every single week
right and this is to ignore the fact
that we update the pendants ease configs
and so forth every single day right and
that's all changed that could lead to a
broken product for
users and so the challenge to us is how
do we maintain this velocity while
achieving you know good confidence that
we can trust the product that goes out
the door right and maintain our users
trust you know based on that and to make
the challenge even greater as QA leaders
as VPS of engineering we are being
tasked to make sure that our products
work on more devices more browsers more
resolutions more permutations of the
client experience than ever before right
and so now you think about you know that
QA leader that has this pace of change
that's just unbelievable coming into the
sort of team and on top of that we're
being tasked to say let's make sure that
it works across you know a wide variety
of devices and so some teams are
struggling to say how do I build out the
infrastructure that I need to make sure
that I can test effectively across all
you know the client experience is that I
have to support and the risk is that we
end up in a position where the QA sort
of function or process is a bottleneck
for development teams right so think
about you know all the innovation that's
happened over the last 10 years
development tools and processes that
enable you as an engineer to build and
ship code faster think of all the great
innovations that have happened in the
DevOps space for you as a sysadmin or an
operator to you know release that code
to production and monitor it and manage
it well where's the innovation for QA
right and so this is what we're focused
on and we actually believe that we're at
the beginning of a new era of what we
call intelligent testing and realizes
intelligent test automation right and
there are some principles that we
believe in here the first one is that
tests have to be able to adapt to change
and what that means is as the product
evolved it has to be very infrequent
that the tests blow up because of a
change to the product that doesn't
actually affect the user experience the
second principle is that we think that
tests are going to be running in the
cloud right we'll talk in a minute about
how automated testing like the execution
of automated tests
is the perfect use case for cloud
computing third we'll talk about how the
tests that get executed the output that
we can't be in the business of reviewing
the output of every test execution that
goes by to confirm that there aren't
issues we need to apply analysis to that
output to tell us when there are issues
right and that's a really important
shift and then finally this all has to
happen in the context of a pipeline we
can't have QA sort of off to the side
trying to you know inspect releases as
they go through because again the pace
is such that it has to be automatic and
automated okay so those are the
principles what we'll do now is we'll
explore each principle in detail and
show you how it works when we integrate
with TCP GCP actually provides a really
compelling foundation for solving a lot
of these problems and so the first
principle was tests have to be able to
adapt to change if any of you have
worked with legacy testing frameworks
you've probably struggled a little bit
with tests that can sort of survive
changes to your front-end for example
anybody work with selenium selenium yeah
okay
and anybody built great selenium test
suite that can seamlessly handle
dramatic changes to the front end
without false positives not one hand
maybe an elbow back there yeah almost
down to those thumbs down right and so
one of the problems we need to solve is
exactly this to make sure that tests
don't break when the user experience
isn't affected because when you have
that situation you're trying to deploy
changes for production rapidly false
positives and tests can create all sorts
of dysfunction right either you stop the
release creating a backup in the
pipeline or you end up with developers
saying a QA you know your tests those
are bad tests and QA saying well you
broke the test why don't you go fix it
right anybody been in that we've been in
that situation I don't even have to ask
and so we created Mabel just as an
illustration to be intent driven and so
what that means is we bet we use a
Chrome extension and as of cue
engineer or a product owner or a support
person or anyone else you basically use
your application as you would expect any
users to and then Mabel captures the
intent of your actions and generates
tests based on that and we'll talk about
how that works in just a second an
important thing here is to look at the
area in red where it says click the
close alert button right and so that's
just a step that Mabel sort of recorded
as you were using the application now
when we run that test in the cloud it
could be that when we get to that step
so you look at the area that's
highlighted in red that that button now
says dismiss right and the XPath changed
the XPath is sort of the location of
that button in the Dom you know the
structure of the webpage now
historically this would be a disaster
for your tests right because anything
that interacted with that button would
fail what we've done with Mabel is
implemented a set of heuristics that say
okay given the intent to quote to click
that button let's go figure out how to
find the button if we can't find it
using the locators that we had
originally and so we've built sort of a
model of that button and every element
that we interact with and so if we can't
find the button where it used to be
we'll find the button using a different
heuristic and we'll make sure that the
test continues to pass and then if it
does we'll update the test right and so
this is an example of how you can create
tests that can survive you know these
dramatic and frequent changes in at
least the front end of an application
and so Joe will talk a little bit about
how we do that on GCP thanks Dan so as
Ben was saying and as any developer here
knows the real problem with continuous
testing these days is brittle tests you
check in a commit 6,000 tests fail so we
really do need to make these tests
automatically adapt and not only do we
make them automatically adapt the system
has to adapt because nobody can go
through 6,000 tests to fix that CSS bug
so here at Mabel is how in GCP we build
a continuous seamless adaptation
workflow we start with everything and
the bottom right here
the cloud datastore which is our storage
place for all the scripts that we're
going to run all the tests and then
these tests get loaded into our testing
cluster and kubernetes which is going to
be able to run hundreds of parallel
instances of that browser and they're
all going that you met tons of
observations hundreds a second as Dan
mentioned how we're building that model
of that page of that element and this
continuous flow goes through cloud
pub/sub and end to cloud dataflow we can
do continuous stream processing and
transforms on this data and we can
determine did something odd happen did
we not find the button did it change its
text but we think we know where it
really is and in some cases we might not
know where it is in that case we would
go out to cloud functions we can call a
script send a slack message what our
user know that something has gone wrong
but in most cases we can actually start
closing this loop we can figure out that
dismiss is actually the correct button
and we can automatically change that
script and say this is the button you
need to click and we can feed back into
our data store we can update that script
and the next time we run we know exactly
where it is and we don't have to adapt
again the test has been healed and by
doing this this continuous flow we
seamlessly adapt and are able to achieve
continuous testing great thank you very
much Joe and and so that's how that's a
general pattern for you know how we can
create tests that survive despite
changes to the structure of the
underlying page so practically speaking
what this means is that for our users
you know putting a maintenance message
at the top of the page that changes the
DOM and the X paths of all the elements
on the page doesn't break the tests
right changing the IDs of elements
doesn't break the test changing the CSS
classes
don't break the test right and so that
makes it so that you don't have a lot of
noise around you know sort of
maintaining the test as part of the
pipeline so that's the first principle
second principle test will run in the
cloud we predict that you know three
years from now we're sitting here
talking and if I ask how many people are
building out you know big farms of test
infrastructure for you know on-premise
we think very few hands are going to go
up
and really that's because as I mentioned
before testing is a great use case for
cloud infrastructure it's a much more
efficient way to run tests and so let's
just talk some numbers here so imagine
your web application you only had 50
test cases or scripts that you want to
run right I'm sure many of you have
orders of magnitude more than that but
let's start small so 50 things let's say
I want to add some items to a card I
want to check out let me search let me
sign up register so on and so forth like
the core of a web application now let's
imagine that for each of those you only
want to test on average three scenarios
so you know users with different
permissions or in different locations or
different credit card numbers and so
forth so let's say just three now you
want to support probably the four major
browsers let's let's say and maybe the
current version and one previous version
so eight eight browser versions and then
you have three environments so you
deploy to QA and then staging and then
prod and you want to test every time you
deploy and then you do three releases a
day right which may sound like oh my god
that's an incredible velocity to many of
you and then some others you'd say well
you know you mean just me not my whole
team correct and so but in this world
you know where you're deploying about
once every eight hours I'm you're
talking about nearly 11,000 tests being
executed a day right so this is real
volume generated from trying to get
decent coverage across only 50 tests
okay now if you wanted to look at let's
say we ran you know Ted we'd created
tests that run pretty quickly
seven minutes each on average you're
talking about nearly 1,300 compute hours
dedicated to executing these tests and
you're talking about a very you know
very simple sort of test suite instead
of scenarios right so this is real
infrastructure that we need to deal with
where it gets kind of crazy is when you
think about the concurrency that's
required in order to execute those tests
within sort of target Windows so if
you're doing a release every eight hours
and you
run you know those tests that we talked
about in the prior slide then sure if
you had 54 nodes of compute executing
tests in parallel you could churn
through them in about 8 hours so before
you do your next release not too bad now
Joe doesn't like to sit around for 8
hours after he does a deployment to wait
to find out at the test pass
in fact he wouldn't even tolerate an
hour but if it was an hour he would we
would need about 420 nodes of compute to
be able to run all those tests within an
hour after the deployment ok now what we
expect and what I think many of you
expect when we get to that sort of
vision of continuous delivery is that
we're talking about minutes to execute
the entire test suite because you want
your engineers to be able to get that
code in production and move on to the
next task and not deal with a bunch of
work in progress and so here we're
talking about 3,600 nodes of compute to
execute those 50 simple scripts right
for you know this application right but
the reason why this is a perfect use
case for cloud computing is because for
how long do you need those 3600 nodes of
compute the line in green here you need
them for about 10 minutes right and so
why would you deal with provisioned
capacity to execute those tests you want
to burst run the tests and then make it
disappear and the efficiency is
basically the entire chart right because
you're only paying for the green spikes
you're not paying for the rest that's at
the most efficient model for executing
those tests and we can show you exactly
how to do it thanks Dan so let's say you
run the bandwagon you want to build your
cloud centric scalable so Neum testing
framework while walking for you Google
cloud platform has google kubernetes
engine now I need to give you a
disclaimer this won't let you test
everything some browsers are limited by
their architectures or licenses like
Internet Explorer Safari on Mac iOS and
Android but excluding those you can
still run run a very robust set up in
the cloud so for example you could use
selenium docker project images
of firefox and chrome and schedule them
on your google kubernetes engine
instances as pots in kubernetes now is
automatically going to find a home for
each one of those pods it's going to
start stacking them up in instances it's
going to efficiently pack them and if it
can't find a home add more instances and
keep adding instances until it can run
all those tests all 10,000 for example
but then when they're done it's going to
start getting rid of nodes scale all the
way back down to 0 this makes it highly
efficient highly cost-effective and it's
actually all very much no ops it just
works
so at Mable for example we have many
such kubernetes clusters but last year
we set up one of them and to date it's
run about 12 million containers and it
really hasn't been touched in a year it
automatically gets up created
automatically maintained it's a very
very robust set up we like to think
about Ronda peel when you look at our
cluster we just say set it and forget it
not again using these tools you are
easily able to take your Sounion
infrastructure and just seamlessly scale
it in the cloud great so what Joe will
show us next is how we've implemented
that in Mable so imagine you didn't want
to you know provision in your own
kubernetes architecture and deal with
the scheduling and execution and all
that yourself if you were to use Mable
let's show them how that would work in
real time if we could bring up the demo
sure so what we have right here now is
an example of what we call a test plan
in Mable in this case we're just going
to kick it off hitting the run button
and what's just happened is our pods as
you can see here for Chrome and for
Firefox have been sent off to be
scheduled on the kubernetes cluster
actual browsers are being spun up and
then we actually here have our different
tests so for example we have find a
shirt and we can see in this case we're
going to go to Nordstrom we're gonna
look for men's shirts and we're going to
assert that we found the proper shirt
and what's going to happen is that Mabel
is going to make all those permutations
it's going to make two tests two
browsers so four containers are going to
spin up and we can see them all right
here looks like they took off about 30
seconds ago all running in parallel
and what's going to happen is Mabel's
making all his observations we showed
you earlier taking all the screenshots
warning everything she can about this
given application under test taking
screenshots and letting us do all this
just in parallel much more scalable than
anything you generally would be able to
find when you're running your own setup
and here we are we've already gone
through we started finding pants and we
are scaling very well in the cloud you
have the slides Ken thank you Joe
and so that's what we're talking about
when we talk about tests being the sort
of automated testing being the ideal
workload for cloud computing all right
we can you know kick off a test fan out
run that test in parallel turn the
resources off and only pay for the
resources for that very short period of
time that we needed them to execute the
test you also noticed it's the
anniversary sale at Nordstrom here so
the third principle test results need to
be more insightful and so the the core
there is as we're executing tens of
thousands of tests over a given you know
release cycle a quarter or year we can't
be dealing with you know each test run
as a special snowflake right Joe would
never go into an application and look at
those logs of the test to make sure that
it's running effectively what he needs
to know is did I break the product right
and otherwise he's going to be on to the
next the next feature that he's working
on and so how do we do that well one
principle for us with making test
results insightful as we think you know
what would Mabel as a persona do right
if Mabel was a manual tester would Mabel
only look at you know sort of the HTML
of the page and as the HTML doing what
it's supposed to do probably not when
Mabel only look at the screenshots and
see if the screenshots were appropriate
probably not right Mabel would want to
look at a variety of sort of aspects of
quality of the application and then
decide whether you know it works or not
based on those right and so what we've
done is built a pipeline that can
capture all these different types of
data we feed that data into an analytics
pipeline and then we generate insights
based on either heuristics or models
that we've implemented to detect when
the applications not performing as we
expected that it should and so here is a
good example we have some very simple
insights right we can use basic
heuristics many of you could build this
one where we attempt to click on every
link in an application and we have
heuristics that says if there's a new
broken link why don't we tell Joe about
it and say you know your last build
actually broke Brooke some links right
simple stuff the next one the
client-side JavaScript error so we'll
capture client-side JavaScript errors
associate them with each step in the
test and the important thing here is
letting people know when there's a
change versus the model or state that we
have of the page right so many of you
probably have lots of client-side
JavaScript errors when you know we load
the app that don't actually hurt the
end-user right and so we're not going to
tell you again and again and again you
know we saw again in this test wake up
at 3 o'clock in the morning because you
have some errors right but what you
might want to know is when I just did a
deployment that on now on step 4 there
are new errors right and so this gives
you a way of preventing you know
technical debt from accruing with these
errors and so these are two heuristics
driven insights that this pipeline gives
us another one model driven insights
around anomalies so think of timing
right so Mabel as a manual QA engineer
would probably love to be able to detect
subtle changes in page load time or test
execution time yeah but that's a
challenging thing for us to do as humans
right running test after test unless you
have a stopwatch right but you're not
you know in control of all of your
actions so what Mabel will do is
captures timing information page load
time test execution time step time and
so forth and then predicts how long it
will take the next time we run a test
and if the actual observation is
different than the prediction then we
serve
and in sight okay and of course Google
cloud and machine learning play an
important part in that the feature that
people are perhaps most excited about
right now with this is detecting visual
anomalies and so our Nordstrom
colleagues in the audience will
appreciate this one when we search for
those pants we started the test a couple
days ago it was the preview of the
anniversary sale right and then a couple
days later we ran the test and the
anniversary sale had been launched and
so what changed you can barely see it
but the menus at the top changed and
that was the first time Mabel had ever
seen those menus changed and so she
flagged it as an anomaly right as an
anomalous change now what you can't
really see you could you know barely see
here is when I run that search for
women's pants the order of the pants
change every time you run the test right
there's a random aspect to how those
load and so Mabel has to be smart enough
to detect expected changes from
unexpected changes and so the model
actually takes these dynamic areas and
says well these are dynamic regions I'm
not going to surface visual anomalies in
those regions because they change too
frequently whereas there are these other
regions that are predictably the same
every time I run the test and if I see
those change then I'll surface Addison
insight and so these are the type of
insights that we're trying to drive
toward in this new era where we're
giving you actionable relevant
information so that then you can dive in
you know when there are potential issues
but it takes a lot of work thankfully we
have some infrastructure that we can
rely on thanks again
so as Dan points out one of these major
limiting factors we have with tests in
general is that they make a lot of noise
as a developer the last thing you want
is yet another report here's 6,000
things you need to fix right now so what
comes out of this process has to be
insightful but also I can Mabel when
we're running on scale and GCP we have
to handle tons and tons of inputs and
figure out which ones are those are
insights and more importantly we have to
tune them down to the exact insight for
that specific custom
whether it's insightful to them so we
start as you saw earlier with our
kubernetes engine which is churning
through you know thousands of web pages
making our continuous feed of
observations coming out and then we feed
it into several different pipelines the
first pipeline is our continuous
prediction pipeline here we harness
cloud dataflow again to work on the data
transform it as necessary and we feed it
into cloud ml and then the cloud machine
warning we run our models against for
example those images or against timing
and we decide did this change is this a
visual anomaly or did this get too slow
or too fast and if that is the case then
we immediately push via pub/sub to cloud
functions so we can notify our user we
want to do that immediately so it's a
timely insight and that for example is
sent out over slack so within about a
second or two from hitting that URL
observing we've popped up a message in
your slack saying we found something as
going way way too slow yes or no is this
good but we can't just tell you that we
want to take that feedback back into the
machine because the machine needs to
understand what's important to you so in
this case cloud functions lets us have
an endpoint that takes that slack
feedback back in and you click on the
yes this is a good insight or no it's
not and we feed that back into another
pipeline our continuous training
pipeline we can do a little wave a
cleanup for example in cloud dataflow
and then again by cloud machine learning
we can update that model make it adapt
to you and tune your insights we won't
give you an insight that's not
insightful to you in the future we put
this back into cloud datastore and that
datastore is the reference of all of
these models so we now have a circle and
we are continuously training and
predicting and training another limiting
factor sometimes with creating the sorts
of insights is maybe of a new model and
we need to change that model we need to
maybe go back to a hundred million
pictures and retrain against all of them
that can be very prohibitive from a
scaling standpoint but using for example
kubernetes engine we can take a brand
new Python ML script we can as we did in
maple this week span up four hundred
machines crush all of those millions of
images update everybody's models and now
we have been able to push something out
that would have been very challenging
previously back into our continuous
prediction and training pipeline all
this being perfectly serviced each one
of these components able to scale up and
down independently with no ops on us all
through using these different service
technologies and Google Cloud thanks Joe
so if you wanted to build this you just
do this right it's not that that hard I
mean the I think the staggering thing
for me is to think about you know where
we are as an industry today and while
this has taken some work to build right
for a team PhDs like making this stuff
happen imagine what it would have taken
10 years ago right where none of these
services existed or at least we're
available to us publicly outside of
Google and so it's actually making it
possible to solve some problems you know
in a very elegant way that weren't
really possible to solve before unless
you were running at incredible scale
right Google scale or what have you and
so that was the third principle right
that test results need to be more
insightful and then the final one is
testing on then needs to be part of a
continuous delivery pipeline right so QA
can't be sort of off to the side it
needs to be fully automated part of the
pipe pipeline and what a pipeline might
look like is something like this right
Joe I'll write some code he'll commit it
we'll do a build execute some unit tests
once that's ready to go we'll deploy to
a QA environment that deployment
generates triggers some tests
once those all pass then we Pro promote
that build to the staging environment or
deploy to staging environment and then
we run some tests on staging those paths
we deployed a prod and then we'll do
some final smoke tests in prod so let's
see what that looks like at scale so as
a quick overview of the demo we're going
to do we're going to show you how we can
create continuous testing and continuous
deployment workflow is tied together to
get us a testing feedback loop in this
case we have a code commit perhaps to
github that can then trigger a
deployment trigger in cloud build which
is going to automatic
we go get our code from get it's going
to build it deploy it tell Mable there's
a new deployment available by its API
that will then come back and test our
app and if it's successful it can call
back to cloud build and keep propagating
through our deploy tests to point test
deploy test cycle so to show you what
that looks like if we could please get
the demo app top the first thing we need
is an app because we have to deploy
something for our continuous deployment
so in this case we have calculated
column ative calculator where we can do
things like addition now this demo is
going to start like all great code
deployment start with a merge so we have
our why Vicki demo pyaar let's hope this
works
let's do it okay so now we just sent
this off into the ether and we're going
to be triggering cloud build and cloud
build should take over now and it's
discovered that we have just started the
deployment and this lets us do a simple
workflow for example we're going to
install our applications dependencies
we're going to build that web app we're
going to push it out to Google Cloud
Storage for static hosting it's actually
gonna give us a dynamic URL and then
we're going to call Mabel's deployment
event API and feed in that dynamic URL
so we can actually run that test against
any different location if we see there
it looks like it's almost done building
our web app but let's talk about what
it's actually going to do so we've got
some more tests here because again for
continuous testing we're going to need
some tests and in this case similar to
before we're going to run across
multiple browsers Chrome and Firefox and
we're gonna do a simple mathematics test
because we need to make sure the math
works inside that calculator we built
and so we have some simple test steps
here for example we want to make sure
that 3 plus 3 equals 6 that's a pretty
good invariant hopefully it holds but
that's only one test and a calculator
can do many things
so we actually
another feature we're going to use oops
let's see and that's called parameterize
testing because we don't want to write
tons and tons of different tests so here
we have something we call a data table
so we have 50 different permutations and
now we can test things like
multiplication division subtraction
negative numbers and now we're getting
100 tests and all we had to do is write
one test so given all that thank you
thank you
this feature is wife by the way so given
all of that now Mabel has already
started and our servers are spending up
here they go off to the races 81 we
should get to a hundred here shortly a
little bit of a burst but again what's
going on all these separate containers
are spinning up we have a hundred
instances pumping in Google cloud that
just turned on for Firefox for Chrome
and they're running all of our tests in
parallel and it looks like they're done
now so that took under two minutes I
believe and in a classic environment
that would have taken three hours and
all that was driven this continuous
testing continuous deployment why are
you making a single commitment whoa all
right so thank you Joe so we've talked
through the four principles that you
know we've been focused on that we think
will sort of underlie this new era of
intelligent testing I know that if you
work in the QA space that's been some
struggle lately keeping up with the pace
of development the good news is there is
hope right we're going to as an industry
find a way to deliver tests that adapt
seamlessly to applications that change
rapidly we're going to run those tests
in the cloud at scale and speed that we
haven't seen before as Joe's demo just
showed us we'll have insights based on
output that are actionable so we don't
have to deal with the individual results
of every test and then also we'll
integrate deeply into automated
pipelines so that we don't have to have
manual intervention at every step in a
release process and it's all powered by
innovations in cloud computing and you
know here in our case in Google cloud
and so I thank you very much for your
time and attention we're here to answer
any questions that
you might have
[Applause]
[Music]